Bienvenidos a reporteros el magazine de
los grandes reportajes de la redacción
de France 24 soy herminia Fernández
comenzamos la migración de venezolanos
hacia Estados Unidos por la frontera con
México aumentó en casi un 300% entre
2021 y 2022 para detener el flujo
desmedido de los ciudadanos venezolanos
el gobierno de yoga y de les aplicó el
artículo 42 que desató miles de
deportaciones en octubre de 2022
Guatemala por su parte También
intensificó las expulsiones de
venezolanos que transitan por su
territorio de forma ilegal en el país
centroamericano los migrantes suelen
denunciar extorsiones y humillaciones de
parte de las autoridades para dejarlos
cruzar nuestros reporteros Aurora wayú y
Andrés Suárez Jaramillo acompañaron la
travesía de dos migrantes venezolanas y
sus hijos por Guatemala para dar un
matrimonio sobre las dificultades que se
enfrentan en apenas 24 horas de viaje en
uno de los tramos de su camino hacia
Estados Unidos
Andrés Europa están hoy en el programa
comienzo con Andrés les saludo ustedes
hicieron el viaje completo con estas
venezolanas por toda Guatemala Cómo
pudieron comprobar que los migrantes que
pasan por el país sufren extorsión
herminia Hola Bueno fíjese que además de
corroborarlo con los testimonios de
muchos migrantes que entrevistamos y de
las propias autoridades altos mandos del
ejército que reconocen que esto es un
flagelo que afecta a Guatemala hubo una
noche en particular en la grabación de
este reportaje en que pudimos
aproximarnos a ver cómo ocurre la
extorsión estábamos en la Estación de
Buses de Puerto Barrios frontera de
Guatemala con Honduras y allí pudimos
ver por ejemplo como unos migrantes
peruanos transaban con el conductor del
autobús para poderse ir en el maletero
de manera que pudieran evitar evadir los
retenes que más adelante se presumen que
es donde ocurre la extorsión las
protagonistas de nuestro reportaje al
viajar con hijos pequeños no lograron
este cometido
auguraban esperaban que no se fueran a
encontrar un retén pero el momento
temido a las 4 de la mañana llegó no les
puedo contar mucho más de lo que sucedió
Los invito para que vean en el reportaje
lo que sí les puedo contar es que este
momento fue muy desafiante para nosotros
como reporteros al grabarlo para que no
fuéramos hacer descubiertos pero sí
pudimos observar como los militares van
directo a los migrantes los bajan y
desde lejos podemos ver lo que ocurre
allí Así que él invitó a que lo vean en
el reportaje Gracias Andrés veamos la
historia
[Música]
atravesar un país puede convertirse en
un viacrucis para las personas que
viajan de forma irregular con rumbo a
Estados Unidos
ahora les voy a molestar un documento
con los
[Música]
identifique en Guatemala la penúltima
nación antes de lograr La hazaña los
migrantes denuncian a mafias de
extorsión como el principal obstáculo
para seguir su camino
personal
es vendedor hay alguien arriba quién
está Hace cuánto subió el teniente de
León flores del ejército de Guatemala
practica una rutina de registro en este
retén a pocos kilómetros de la frontera
con Honduras
damas y caballeros muy buenos días
Por favor les vamos a requerir que se
puedan identificar los guatemaltecos con
su respectivo dpi pasaporte y los
ciudadanos extranjeros que se puedan
identificar con el documento respectivo
de su país de origen ya sea la cédula
pasaporte o visa
cada mes un promedio de 50.000 migrantes
sudamericanos cruzan por Guatemala
so pena de ser expulsados Por no tener
Visa O pasaporte muchos contratan
traficantes de personas o los
denominados coyotes quienes los cruzan
clandestinamente evadiendo las
autoridades los que no como estos
dominicanos y apuestan a un golpe de
suerte
los inmigrantes no lo quieren dar pasar
ya
[Música]
en este país está bien que somos
inmigrantes estamos entrando ilegal Pero
uno lo que quiere cruzar ya cruzar de
aquí para entrarse al México y de México
así hace lo mismo que aquí ya el plan es
ya Estados Unidos
a la luz del día este grupo de
dominicanos es devuelto a la aduana
migratoria deshinchado entre Guatemala y
Honduras convencer a los agentes
migratorios requiere según lo que los
propios migrantes denuncian un pago
extraoficial dicho pago Se realiza
dentro de una camioneta gris A las
afueras de esta aduana y el valor varía
de acuerdo con la nacionalidad
el caso concreto le sucedió a estas dos
venezolanas y sus hijos Erika y Némesis
de 29 y 24 años respectivamente al no
poder cruzar los retenes por la ausencia
de pasaporte y visa tuvieron que pagar
un precio muy alto
no devuelven me dice que tenemos que
comprar que tenemos que comprar un
tiquete nos indican dónde según tenemos
que comprar el tiquete en una camioneta
gris
llegamos hasta el sitio pues ahí no era
ningún punto de migración y nada era
algo o sea normal
hablamos con unas personas que estaban
ahí y empezaron a decir que bueno como
éramos venezolanas como somos
venezolanas tenemos que pagar 80 dólares
cada uno Aunque estas dos amigas y
cuñadas ya sabían por el voz a voz que
para cruzar Guatemala debían pagar
algunos sobornos desconocían el
sentimiento de vivirlo en carne propia
frustración porque al ver que habían
otras personas que
nos veíamos
porque somos seres humanos todos aunque
seamos inmigrantes
Erika y Némesis partieron de Venezuela
en dirección a Estados Unidos escapando
de la crisis económica como lo han hecho
otros siete millones de venezolanos en
su periplo por Centroamérica se
enteraron que el presidente de Estados
Unidos Joe biden ordenó deportar a
cualquier venezolano que cruce
ilegalmente la frontera Sur desde
octubre de 2022 antes que devolverse
ellas confían que acompañadas de sus
hijos menores podrán entrar sin que las
deporten
haciendo escala en Puerto Barrios la
primera ciudad de Guatemala tras la
frontera con Honduras es momento de
tomar un baño tras dos días sin hacerlo
y el tema higiénico durante la travesía
como es Cómo se siente uno
desde que salieron de su país cada favor
tiene su precio
[Aplausos]
en la estación de autobuses de Puerto
Barrios ha llegado el momento de
embarcarse
me me tocó el 45 y el 46 con Adrián
pero no te tocaron con los niños y ahora
toca que hables con el chofer así como
dijeron allá con el señor del puesto
para que nos cambie el puesto para que
queden los niños juntos
no tener asientos juntos en el autobús
es el menor de los temores de Erika y
Némesis con antelación un migrante
peruano que va más adelante en la
carretera les advirtió que durante el
viaje de 7 horas hasta ciudad de
Guatemala se encuentra otro retén donde
presuntamente los extorsionan
se me dan miedo pero esperemos que no
que no vayan a parar y que no haya retén
no vayan a bajar del bus
la ruta que Erika y Némesis eligieron
para cruzar Guatemala tiene un primer
tramo nocturno desde Puerto Barrios
hasta ciudad de Guatemala una ruta menos
peligrosa y más corta que la que
atraviesa la selva del departamento
Norteño de Petén transitada por
narcotraficantes
después de 5 horas viajando de camino a
la capital sucedió lo que tanto temían
un punto de control del ejército detuvo
el autobús en la madrugada y los
militares exigieron a Erika y Némesis
bajarse del vehículo
su versión sobre lo sucedido solo la
conoceríamos al llegar al terminal de la
capital guatemalteca
primero nos abrieron los documentos
luego dijeron que bajáramos los tres y
ahí ya nos pidieron 20 dólares por
persona no
que teníamos que pagar y después yo dije
que no tenía en dólar que tenía en
quetzales Y entonces que tenían que
revisarlo
me tocaron
y después llegó otro y también quería lo
mismo cierto también quería revisarme
no me gusta
porque no
sé creo que como que el peor de los
países que por los que he pasado
o sea el más fuerte no sé
la versión del ejército no fue posible
de obtener sin embargo fuera de cámaras
algunos comandantes dijeron a France 24
que el soborno de parte de los agentes
en los puestos de control es frecuente
según investigaciones de la fiscalía
contra el tráfico ilícito de migrantes
algunos policías de Guatemala reciben
hasta 1000 dólares para permitir el paso
de migrantes sin contar el maltrato a
las mujeres pero como Erika y Némesis la
mayoría de los migrantes se rehúsa a
denunciar oficialmente por el miedo y su
afán de atravesar el país
a la frontera
Cuánto hace la frontera 150 cada uno sí
tenemos que mirar el dinero
que vamos a ver si tenemos el dinero
para pagarte déjame
sin detenerse ni siquiera para desayunar
el segundo trayecto de Erika y Némesis
consiste en tomar un autobús desde
ciudad de Guatemala hasta la ciudad
fronteriza con México llamada Tecún Umán
un recorrido de 7 horas durante el día
instaladas en un segundo autobús El
ayudante del conductor les cobra también
por los niños Erika se niega al
principio pero finalmente también paga
por ellos
[Música]
mientras recorren Guatemala de día los
trayectos les dejan tiempo para recordar
el camino que han atravesado días atrás
el más estremecedor para Némesis es el
paso por el tapón del Darién la selva
que separa a Colombia de Panamá
Detrás de mi bote embarcaron a cuatro
niños
sin papá sin mamá sin nada los
embarcaron porque ya no podían eran
muchas horas que habíamos estado
caminando en pantanos y los niños venían
con el desorden y se volteó el pote y se
ahogaron los cuatro niños yo estuve seis
días con ellos con los niños me decía
mami no puedo más yo quiero salir de
este campamento
y habían veces que yo se me salían las
lágrimas porque yo no podía y verlos a
ellos llorar me partía el corazón Yo
decía yo tengo que salir de aquí
[Música]
en una parada durante el camino Erika
consiguió señal para coordinar con
algunos amigos migrantes el paso a
seguir una vez lleguen a la frontera con
México no me dijeron que consiguieron un
señor y el señor les cobró 50 dólares
para cruzarlos y le dejaban en Tapachula
las dos madres y sus hijos arriban a la
ciudad fronteriza de Tecún Umán
ahora el objetivo es llegar en bicitaxis
al río Suchiate la frontera natural que
separa a Guatemala de México pero antes
es necesario cambiar Divisas en su viaje
migratorio Erika y Némesis han negociado
en dólares pesos colombianos colones
costarricenses córdobas nicaragüenses
lempiras hondureñas y ahora se despiden
de Los Quetzales guatemaltecos
a cambio los Quetzales que tenía por
peso mexicano porque ya estamos a punto
de pasar a México
finalmente Erika y Némesis llegan al
paso del coyote donde un último
obstáculo les Espera los locales se
quieren aprovechar del desespero de las
dos mujeres por llegar a México un
balsero alcanza a cobrarles hasta 500
dólares por cruzarlas por el río Pero
ellas resuelven pagar lo que normalmente
se paga
un promedio de un dólar por persona
aportas de pasar su séptima frontera
Erika y Némesis no perdonan a Guatemala
esa sensación desagradable que les deja
pues que no deberían existir más
personas así como las personas de
Guatemala
son muy inhumanas
y pues nada palante con mucha fe
cruzar Guatemala apenas les tardó un día
atrás queda ese trago amargo llamado
extorsión por delante está el último
país que tendrán que atravesar antes de
cumplir el sueño americano
lo que en ese momento no vaticinan es
que días después al poner pie en Estados
Unidos Erika y Némesis serían
inmediatamente aprendidas por las
autoridades migratorias sin importar que
viajaran con sus hijos pequeños con la
mala suerte de que fueron deportadas a
México donde quedaron sumidas en un
limbo administrativo
estamos de vuelta con Aurora wayuu
Aurora acompañaron a esta familia
durante su viaje por Guatemala qué
pudieron notar sobre el trato de las
personas hacia ellos en el camino
Bueno pues al acompañarlas obviamente
llegó un momento en que nosotros también
íbamos con la ropa sucia las ojeras las
maletas como estábamos en zonas
sensibles tampoco íbamos con el
micrófono France 24 así súper visible
más bien bajo perfil Entonces era fácil
confundirnos con personas migrantes que
fue lo que pasó y sencillo en ese
momento que de repente se esfumaron los
buenos modales bien sea en la calle en
las tiendas con los vendedores con los
transportistas nos quisieron estafar
duplicando el precio de un trayecto de
bus
Némesis y Erika iban indignadas pero
también es algo que les tocó durante
todo su viaje entonces obviamente
nosotros vivimos una décima parte de
todo lo que habían vivido ellas pero aún
así fue doloroso asistir a esa
discriminación que muchas personas
migrantes denunciando en ese trayecto
hasta Estados Unidos Gracias Aurora
hasta aquí reporteros de la semana
recuerde que para sintonizar esta y las
emisiones anteriores puede visitar
nuestro sitio web France 24.com hasta la
próxima